in that same LA Times article George the
writer says Martin just isn't I wasn't
going to go to here but you mentioned an
F scott Fitzgerald and you know kind of
a bobble head for Gatsby
Martin transports us back to the halls
of power and that's why a song of fire
and ice often feels less like a Santa a
fantasy saga and more like Doris Kearns
Goodwin 's team of rivals how much has
history influenced your writing in this
series but it's unfortunate
usually I mean I history was my minor in
college I've always loved reading
history particularly medieval history
but I also read a lot of ancient history
and occasionally other periods it's
especially cool to read history about
countries and times that I know nothing
about rather than the you know the same
old stories that we're taught all
through high school and college and such
but one of the things I wanted to do
when I started writing this series was
to weld the the the Wonder and and
imagination of the the very best fantasy
and science fiction with some of the
grittiness of historical fiction in
addition to history I read a lot of
historical fiction and for me it
fulfills some of the same stuff of
fantasies takes us to another place
another time a place where more rays
were different and yet in historical
fiction there's there's a sense of
realism that I found very attractive and
I'm a huge Tolkien fan certainly he was
a giant influence over me but fantasy in
in the hands of the imitators who
followed Tolkien I think had kind of
lost its way they were they were taking
a lot of Tolkien's tropes and just
repeating them and they didn't have
Tolkien was a real scholar and a
linguist and an expert in folklore and
ancient languages and he brought all of
this considerable learning to it that
wasn't true of the token imitators they
were taking just a Bordas you know
castles and knights and and and Dark
Lords and stuff from token and producing
this stuff that seemed to be me to be
set in that Disneyland Middle Ages are
rather than anything approximating the
real Middle Ages so so history you know
which was huge for me
and as I read a lot of history you know
is that famous quote that if you steal
from one person is plagiarism if you
steal from many people as research I I
stole from many people reading a lot of
history and I would say to my wife as I
read some of these histories you can't
make this stuff up listen to what
happened here and I'd read some
incredible incident and then you know I
if I lost the serial numbers and change
a few things and do a version of that
from my books so something like the red
wedding as I've said in other interviews
was very much inspired by the black
dinner of Scotland and the Glencoe
massacre both from Scotland Scotland has
a lot of incredibly bloody history which
is a particularly particularly good of
course the word of roses was a huge
influence over everything the Hundred
Years War
all of that was was grist for the mill
so in addition to historical references
do you believe do you also think of Song
of Ice and Fire as it's kind of relating
to current does it function not only as
historical reference in some ways but
political allegory right in the way that
your work deals with issues you know
Warren piece family loyalties or
national divisions how do you you know
and there is a long history of science
fiction and fantasy functioning is sort
of historical allegory political
allegory do you do you think your work
functions in that way well I think some
of that is probably there but it's not
necessarily there deliberately I think
you're obviously your influence as a
writer by the world you live in and the
things you see on the news and and the
forces that have shaped you from your
childhood to that all of that goes
and it comes out in some ways but I'm
not writing conscious allegory cocaine
was accused of that of course it always
made him very angry because he hated
allegory but you know when people said
well the Lord of rings as an allegory
for world war two he ejected it
vehemently but there's no doubt that I
think some of that some of that is there
some of this is just universal concerns
I mean I'm writing about power I'm
writing about governance I'm reading
about war yes there are differences but
the things that are true about the war
in Iraq are also true about Caesar's
invasion of Gaul and and Alexander's
conquests of Persia there are certain
universals that that they go through
history and those are inevitably present